Hello and thank you for joining us today.
So today, we are going to talk about ways
to use a NCBI account in a traditional capacity
as a professor or instructor in a college
or university or as an AP biology teacher.
My name is Rana Morris, and Sherry Holland
Bailey is here also.
I've been in a professor's shoes so I have
an idea of what you do, Sherry is an expert
in the NCBI account system so she will have
good technical information if you have specific
questions.
So professors, you are busy, really busy,
in your capacity you have to develop and teacher
courses, labs, coordinate and run your journal
clubs and seminars, direct your lab's research
efforts, write grants and publications, counsel
and mentor your students, and while doing
this stay current on everything related to
both teaching and research topics.
NCBI has information that would help most
of these efforts, but there are so many interesting
records and so little time to organize them
for efficient use.
Sign up for a free NCBI account or if you
already have one we will show you some ideas
as to how to organize your important list
and how to use them in what you are already
doing.
This webinar will show you how to use the
NCBI account and give you some ideas that
I have thought of.
You will see how to save searches and get
automated updates with publications and databases
are available, maintain custom collections
of important records used in coursework and
research projects, create lists of publications
or database records to send your courses,
journal clubs or research teams and maintain
your bibliography, create a URL to share,
and often you need to post your listing of
publications on your faculty profile page
and we will show you how to get a URL to put
on that faculty profile page.
Finally to reuse this information to quickly
create a federal government Bio Sketch that
you can use in your granting, all with the
click of the mouse.
You can keep track of everything right on
your My NCBI dashboard.
So first, you need to sign up for a NCBI account.
The steps are outlined here there is a lot
of information here in the information provided
to you on how to do this.
At the header of virtually all the pages is
a link that says sign into the NCBI.
If you click there you will get to a page
that looks like this, that has a way to sign
in, either directly to NCBI or using Google
accounts, at the bottom is a link to register
or a NCBI account.
You can click this button here to set up your
registration and if you do you will actually
see a screen that says success, you are signed
in.
To verify your email address to make sure
this really is you we will send you an email
it looks like this.
And has a link to validate or activate your
NCBI account.
And then you will login and see that your
email address is confirmed.
Again the registration pages direct URL is
listed here, www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/account/register/.
We actually have a NCBI help book that has
step-by-step instructions.
Or if you already have an account, you can
sign in and actually find this directly here,
or you can sign in with your Google, NIH login,
ERA Commons or other accounts.
Again there is a direct sign in link, www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/account/
and a step-by-step help book in case you need
it.
Once you are logged in, you will notice again
the top header of most of the pages there
are three links here, one of them is your
username, in my case, ncbiprofessor, that
will actually take you over to a page that
will allow you to take a look at your account
settings.
Here you can actually change your password
if you need to, you can change your security
question, you can add additional accounts,
such as ERA commons, in case you are trying
to get a grant, there are other things you
can do as well based on your account.
If you click on My NCBI it will actually take
you to a dashboard, and this is what we will
take a look at today this particular dashboard
view is helpful to keep track of all of your
various lists and collections.
The nice thing is that the NCBI account does
have a help book on the bookshelf, www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/books/NBK3842/,
that really has step-by-step instructions
of virtually everything you would think or
don't even know that you need to do.
On the dashboard, you can customize this page,
you can actually reorganize or get rid of
or move these portlets around, these widgets
around to something that is helpful for you.
There is a youtube video overview that we
have created that will literally step you
through the entire process of how to make
this page look exactly like would like it
to look.
Called My NCBI Home Page.
What can you do with this?
As a professor you probably already search
lots of databases, PubMed, you can search
Gene, MedGen, even PubChem.
Often you want to find and collect materials
for teaching you may want to keep up with
your research competitors and what's going
on in that field, check on your own publications,
are they listed in PubMed, PMC?
I've often been told about a relative's diagnosis
and they want me to check out information
because they think I can find information
for you.
You need to search routinely various databases
I'm sure you would love to be notified when
new records are available, you can do this
in the Save Searches widget on your dashboard,
these are two that are there currently on
the ncbiprofessor dashboard, malaria and lactate
dehydrogenase research projects, and my father's
age-related macular degeneration file as well.
Often, you need to create collections of materials,
maybe you have printed list of references
sitting on your desk, or digital lists on
your office computer desktop somewhere, or
maybe you have a wall filled with sticky notes
or a drawer full of bar napkins, is how I
used to collect them, it would be really great
to find a way to organize custom sets of records
and be able to access them from everywhere.
From your office computer, your phone if you
are in a meeting, at home in the middle of
the night when you're actually doing some
additional work.
You can do all of this by saving your list
in your collections widget which again is
on the dashboard.
These again are some examples of things that
I've set up as a professor, maybe a freshman
seminar on malaria, and the international
implications.
And LDH biochemistry lab folder, and mom's
or dad's macular degeneration.
Once you have all of these lists and you have
created these collections you often need to
share them with students, colleagues or administrators.
There are a lot of reasons to share list,
maybe reading a reference list for courses
or labs or journal clubs or seminars may be
again you want to have that link on your faculty
profile page of all of these publications.
Maybe you need to share them with the administration
so that they can see your productivity.
You can share these collections also and I
will show you how.
This is a quick overview again I will not
go through too many details, I will show you
in a demonstration and a little bit on the
live site, if it lets me.
Once you've actually done an interesting search,
you can save it, underneath the text box is
a Create alert button which will take you
to a page that will allow you to save a search
and simultaneously set up an alert system
that will send you an email when there are
new records.
And I will show you how to do that.
Again, there is a great webinar video, www.youtube.com/watch?v=WbFjV91YNNY&t=9s,
that will show you how to do this or there
are step-by-step instructions in that help
book, www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/books/NBK53592/
You can create collections, online, which
you can access anywhere.
As an example let's say you do a search in
PubMed and find a great bunch of records you
want to save and create a brand-new collection
without you can, just click the Send to link
in the upper link, collections, add to collections
and you can either create a new one, or send
to an existing collection.
That works if you are on the results summary
list, it also will work if you happen to be
on a particular record page where you can
send that record, either to a new collection
or to an existing collection.
It is not just PubMed, it is also Gene, and
many of the other databases as well.
Step-by-step instructions again are available
in the NCBI account help book.
Finally for now, it would be very helpful
to make available or share these lists of
references with students colleagues and administrators,
you can set up specific collection folders
just to do that.
Once you have identified a particular collection
such as the LDH lab collection that you want
to share, you need to change the default designation
over here.
Private means you are the only one that can
access, that is the default.
If you change that to public, it will actually
give you a URL, after you save it, that you
can post, and share with people and then people
will be able to see the content of that particular
collection.
I'm sure this is a bit complicated, but it
is not too bad actually, let me demonstrate
this to you live.
I will sign into an NCBI account, do a search
save this search and create an alert, we will
create a new collection, we will save a record
to the collection, and then we will make that
collection public and share the URL.
For this demonstration we will find a reference
to start as student off with a senior project.
She will be reseaarching malarial diagnostics
focusing in on the lactate dehydrogenase enzyme
as a target for detection and eventual drug
design.
The first thing I want to do is to sign into
the NCBI, so that I can start a collection
that I can share with her.
This is the NCBI homepage, let me show you
how to sign in to NCBI in the upper right-hand
corner, there is the hyperlink to sign in,
when you click it, it will open up this page.
I already have a NCBI account so I'm going
to sign in directly.
ncbiprofessor, see if I can remember my password.
It is still spinning in the upper corner,
I am logged in, I know I am logged in because
now in the upper right-hand corner it does
not say sign in it says ncbiprofessor, if
I click here it will allow me to going to
the account settings change my password if
needed.
The My NCBI link will allow me to go to the
dashboard, we are going to take a look at
that dashboard.
These are lots of widgets, there are all sorts
of widgets, save searches, collections my
bibliography, SciENcv, there is even a blast
history widget.
And you can click and drag and move things
around if you would like to or even get rid
of them.
Again, there is a video overview that will
show you an actual video of how to do this,
and there is also the help link as well.
So first, I will go back to the homepage and
I will click the double helix in NCBI to do
that, and I will start a search in PubMed
to see a couple of publications I would like
the student to be able to read.
What we will do is to research articles about
malaria, and diagnostics.
What I will do is go to PubMed, and we will
search for malaria AND diagnostic AND, the
particular enzyme that I want her to concentrate
on, lactate dehydrogenase.
Will run the search, and we will pull up a
number of publications related to this.
This is a senior students, so I want to give
her a few review articles for her to look
at.
On the left-hand side of the screen I will
click Review, and then to make it easier for
her also, we will go ahead and click those
that are just free full text.
Because of that we can pull some in the PMC
database, you can see that here under Free
PMC article and she can access the entire
text article wherever she is.
I will pick a few of them that are interesting,
one is the Recent Progress in the Development
of Diagnostic Tests for Malaria, and other
good one, Biomarkers and their applications
for rapid and reliable detection of malaria,
specifically talking about the enzyme.
The fourth one, Malaria rapid diagnostic tests
in endemic settings.
Those are three particularly good articles
and we will go ahead and save them to a collection.
What we will do, is to click Send to, collections,
there are three items here that I have selected,
so I will add to collections.
Now if I had not checked any of those boxes,
it would have sent everything.
And although it is not obvious that actually
works very well if you are trying to do a
large set and append it.
We will start a brand-new collection for this,
directly for the student, we will call this
malarial diagnostics.
And click save.
This is going to go ahead and create a new
collection for me.
And in fact it is going to show up right here.
I will open up the dashboard, in a new tab,
so you can take a look and make sure that
that collection is actually created and added
onto my dashboard.
Here is the collections and their it is right
of the bottom, malarial diagnostics, and there
are three articles.
Now I'm going to go back really quickly to
the original search, remember I said that
it would be nice if it would just let me know,
this is an interesting topic to me wouldn't
it be great if it would give me an alert and
let me know when there are new articles?
So I'm going to go ahead and underneath this
say Create alert.
And this is going to do two things at once,
one of them is it will actually create a saved
search for me, I can just rerun the search
again if I want.
But at the same time, because I clicked create
alert I will go ahead and say yes, I would
like to have email updates of new search results.
So yes please.
Email them to me or I can have them email
directly to the student if I wanted.
The schedule, monthly, I could make it more
often than that, for now we will stick with
monthly, the first Sunday of the month, give
me a summary report formats don't show me
all of the abstracts I'll go there when I'm
interested, and send at most five items.
I can do more if I want.
But for now I will stick with five and then
I will click this checkbox, I like to do that,
Send even when there are no new results, just
to make sure that I know it's actually working.
The nice thing is, not only is this search
actually the one that they will redo, but
it also includes the filters, Review and the
free full text, all of that is already included.
I will click Save.
And then I will take a look back at our dashboard
again, and I will reload the dashboard.
We will take a look and make sure that that
search was actually added to my dashboard
and here it is.
Malaria AND diagnostic AND "lactate dehydrogase"
When was the last search?
Today.
As an example, the age-related macular degeneration
one that I already had, it was searched four
days ago because that is when I created it,
since that initial search there are 22 new
articles that have come out with that particular
search.
So I now have an email alert monthly, sending
to me about malaria diagnostic and LDH.
I have a really great collection, beginning
collection with three articles on it, but
let's add one more thing.
It does not have to just be literature it
could be something else as well.
Because I am interested in having her actually
do research on the malarial enzyme, let's
go ahead and add the gene record for the enzyme.
The malarial organism is called Plasmodium
falciparum.
We will look specifically for a Gene record
that will have information about that particular
enzyme.
Our gene database if you're not familiar is
a summary site that has a link to everything
we know about that particular gene.
The enzyme there are a couple of enzymes with
the activity the classic is the one at the
top this one at the top we are going to actually
go ahead and add that to the same collection.
We will create a mixed collection of those
three publications, and the gene record.
I will go ahead and click the send to link,
then I will click add to the collection.
And then I will say do you want to start a
new collection or append to an existing collection,
I want to go to an existing collection, I
want to go to that malarial diagnostics.
I will hit save, and allow it to append that
gene record.
Directly to the existing collection.
New items were added to your collection, so
I will come back to the My NCBI dashboard,
here is the malarial diagnostics that originally
had three, I am reloading the page, and now
we have four.
If I want to make sure the student has access
to this particular collection, right now it
is private, if I click the private link I
can actually change that to public, from private
to public, and when I do that and save it,
it will allow me to have an actual URL that
I can then share with the students.
And here is the URL, right here.
That is the URL that I can share with the
student, and this is what the student will
see, My NCBI Collections, here are the four
records, here are the publications, and here
is that gene.
Again there are YouTube videos, and step-by-step
instructions as to how to do exactly what
I've just shown you so if you have questions
there are plenty of ways depending on whether
you like videos or step-by-step instructions.
Another common thing that you often need to
do as a professor is to maintain a bibliography
listing, a publication listing for various
purposes whether it is populating the publications
selection of your CV, for the department or
school admin annual report you have to file,
or to list your productivity under your University
faculty page, your NCBI dashboard has a widget
called My Bibliography.
My bibliography is just a specialty collection,
you can see it listed in the collections,
this collection is for PubMed records, but
you can also add non-NCBI records to it, such
as non-PubMed journals if you are a chemistry
professor and you have a publication in a
chemistry journal that is not listed in PubMed,
you can actually manually type it in, textbook
chapters, book chapters that you have actually
written you can include there as well.
You can add those to that my bibliography
collection.
Just as for other collections once you are
happy with it you can make it public and use
the URL to share or even post on your faculty
page.
How do you do this?
Click Manage My bibliography and you can see
the page that looks like this, at the top
is a link right here where you can make your
bibliography, it is currently private, you
can make it public, and again use that URL
just like I showed you before.
And here is the public listing of your publication.
Then you can add that directly to your faculty
profile page, or your webpage and people will
automatically see the up to date list.
If you do it this way you only need to maintain
your my bibliography listing add new publications
as they come out and anyone who has this link
will always have the up-to-date list.
Without you having to do any extra work.
Additionally you can use my bibliography listing
to export the entire list to a citation manager
for adding references for your next publication.
You can also use this listing to make a Bio
Sketch to add to your federal grant proposal
without having to do too much extra work.
A lot of the instructions about my bibliography
are available in the helpbook, and also the
step-by-step instructions to share your bibliography.
www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/books/NBK53595/
Now preparing a federal grant proposal is
hard enough, often it gets pretty devious,
NCBI has worked as a team with a number of
other organizations and federal agencies used
to create a tool to help you simplify the
Bio Sketch generation process.
The dashboard widget is called SciENcv.
It is designed to repurpose the information
that you've already listed in your bibliography
along with stored information that you put
into the NCBI account and for NIH grants,
your ERA Commons account.
It takes this information and populates and
automatically formats your NIH or NSF Bio
Sketch.
So again, My Bibliography is a normal collection,
and SciENcv uses that information.
You can manage SciENcv by creating a new Bio
Sketch, and you can select do I want an NIH
Bio Sketch or an NSF Bio Sketch and there
are other agencies and organizations coming
online in the future.
You can choose your data source whether it
is an existing Bio Sketch or another additional
things such as ERA Commons or ORCID, then
you can create your Bio Sketch, you can export
it as a Word document or a PDF.
Here is an example of an NIH and NSF Bio Sketch.
Once you have the grant, congratulations,
you're my bibliography will help you monitor
your compliance with the required NIH Public
access policy and will also assist with the
preparation of your annual and final reports
because you have your publication listing
at NCBI.
We won't get into that right now, in this
webinar, we've produced others that talked
extensively about this and there are many
document that will help you with this, and
the handout that you were given, and there
will also be in the blog, will also have links
to managing NIH public access compliance.
I want to warn you, or perhaps alert you to
a couple of new developments.
NCBI has slowly recently been shifting over
to a new design principle, user centered design.
This means we will be updating our resources
and webpages with more modern and usable layouts,
based both on what users need to do, and also
rounds of testing with real people even before
we release them.
This may impact you in the near future into
specific ways.
Coming in the fall of 2018, there will be
a new look for the my bibliography widget.
This is how it currently looks, and here is
a preliminary design of what it might look
like when is release this fall.
We have done this to fix issues and solve
concerns that many customers have expressed
to us, but also come up with a few of our
own ideas about how we could really make things
better and easier to do.
We are currently in rounds of testing, but
one thing I would like to make sure you know
is that everything that you do now, will already
be included in the new system and be fully
available in the system, you don't need to
wait until it comes out.
Start getting used to the system, put your
information in and will automatically be converted
over.
We hope the new pages will be a whole lot
easier than the current ones.
As it gets closer to the release of the new
system this fall we will do another webinar
to show you exactly the what it looks like,
and how it will work.
And other announcement is that coming in spring
of 2019, there will be a new look for PubMed.
It's been a while since it has been redesigned,
this is what it looks like now, as I'm sure
you know, in this recent version, as mobile
devices have become more prevalent there's
been an attempt to use as a mobile feature
which works fairly well but it doesn't have
all of the features, including a lot of the
MyNCBI features.
We would like to make this user interface
more modern, easier to use and better on all
screens regardless of the size.
For the past several months we have been running
an experiment called PubMed labs, if you take
a look at the PubMed labs you may see what
the new version of it might be like, we will
show you that in a second, please know that
we will have a lot of announcements and webinars
not only letting you know when this is going
to happen, but also showing you how to use
the new pages.
To get a clue as to the direction that we
are going, you can try out PubMed labs, the
URL is at the top of the page,
www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/labs/pubed
this is an online fully functional sandbox
for testing out layouts, features and functions,
with the full set of PubMed data, you won't
actually miss any of the data.
It is all included in PubMed labs.
People have expressed to us already that it
seems to be easier to use, and easier to read,
we've been able to add new functionality that
many people have been asking for.
Is pretty nice for large screens and computer
desktops but it also seems to work fairly
well on mobile devices.
Please keep in mind that PubMed labs is not
yet fully compatible with the NCBI account
and dashboard, but before it is actually released
at PubMed, and released to the wild it definitely
will include all of the My Ncbi features.
I've gone over a lot of stuff, there's always
more things happening at NCBI, if you want
to keep up with what is happening including
information about new developments, coming
webinars, when we put out cool new YouTube
tutorials you can scroll to the bottom of
any of your webpages and click on any of the
social media links.
Or you can watch a webinar that we did on
keeping up with the NCBI that is on YouTube
right now.
Finally if you have any questions or need
help with resources, please do not hesitate
to send an email to info@ncbi.,nlm.nih.gov.
And we will get right back to you.
Thank you very much, and Sherry and I will
be very happy to attempt to answer any questions
that you might have.
[Peter Cooper] Thank you Rana, we are at time,
but we will keep it open and answer some of
these questions.
The first one I will answer, I think I understand
the answer, and then I will have Sherry and
Rana talk about some of the other ones.
One question was how public is the public
URL created for the collection.
The answer is that URL whoever wants to see
it will have to have the URL, it is not indexed
by a search engine so no one should be able
to find it.
The second question is one that we can talk
a little bit about the pros and cons of these
two approaches, the question is do you recommend
the save search feature or collection feature
for sharing a systematic review list of resources?
I will let Sherry address that.
[Sherry Bailey] Great question, the answer
to that question is it depends on what you
want to do.
For the save search, it will give you everything
that is indexed, based on your search.
So that means something could've been written
for example in 2007, if that is not in your
search but it was indexed recently, it will
show up in that email saved search.
If that is all that you care about, are things
related to that topic it is perfect for you.
For a collection, these are things you want
to save, and refer back to later.
So honestly the best answer for this question
is you can use them in tandem with each other.
You can use the save search feature to pull
that documentation for you, all those citations,
then the ones you want to save and perhaps
share you would put to the collection itself.
[Peter] Thank you Sherry.
I think Sherry also addressed the second part
of the question which was about the search
strategy, which would be present in the email
but not in the collection itself.
Somebody had encountered problems, they said
if you have a mixed collection, for example
with Gene results and PubMed results, the
patient would not be able to open the collection.
I do not know that that is true.
We will let Sherry talk about that.
[Sherry] They have been making changes to
how collections work.
For the particular example that Rana used,
she used a gene as well as a PubMed, you can
try this out in your own account as well and
I just tried it out here, it does work, it
depends on what you are trying to do with
the collection.
If you are just going through and sharing
this information it is fine, if you are taking
the information and trying to incorporate
it into another collection, that is where
you will run into a little bit of a problem,
we are working on that as well.
[Peter] Okay, those of the questions that
we have so far, so I will go ahead and ask
Rana to end the webinar and thank you all
for coming, we will talk to you next time.